Ok, so today it's Fatou Guinea for Brut.
You didn't expect to see me here, did you...
I'm going to talk to you about the women of shadows in Hip Hop.
When we talk about rap, we talk about butts, about twerking,
we don't talk about women who are working their butts off in the shadow.
Anyway, it's always us!
But you know, we're still here:
we're always here.
You just can't see us...
With Brut, we met with three women
on top of the rap game.
We'll start with Leïla Sy,
she's a filmmaker,
she's worked with many people:
Fianso, Jul, Youssoupha, Orelsan, Vald and others...
And she is currently
blowing up on Netlfix
with the movie "Banlieusards",
that she co-directed with Kery James.
We're going meet with her on
the set of her latest video clip.
When I say "louder",
I need to be able
to hear you above le playback master.
One of us is going
to stay on the ground.
I didn't want, but
I'm going to kill a man.
T-max, GP 800. Demba.
Actually: no innocent people.
Wads of cash won't be able
to clean up the blood, eh.
Cool!
It's perfect, I love you guys.
My name is Leïla Sy.
I'm a filmmaker, artistic director
Ah, that's amazing.
I started dancing at the age of 11
and that's when I discovered hip hop,
music, audio, rap and
everything that goes with it.
Thank you so much.
No but okay. Come on, let's go shoot.
You good here?
Do you want me to calm down
everything that's going on?
Nah, nah it's good.
No but I'm going to.
Yeah please.
I need everybody to calm down a bit
please, I'm going to need silence!
Silence please!
You are in character.
We're not talking about knitting.
We're talking about killing a man.
Alright let's do it,
let's get in position!
Hip hop culture has been a kind of tutor,
around which I was able to grow up
but not in a rigid way...
In a very free and flexible way.
This is the body: you have to exaggerate!
Action!
No one moves! Bakary : in position !
Do not move!
And music!
Women of shadows... This is an issue that
has been surfacing over the last 2-3 years.
At the time, I didn't look to see if
I was working with a girl or a guy.
I worked with individuals, I worked with
creative people, I worked with artists.
Keep you hand like this.
Now, I'm way more attentive,
in recent years,
when we ask me to give
my opinion on the matter.
Cut!
Thank you very much. Bravo.
We're starting to get something good.
Careful, Mr. Kery James has just
arrived, so no more messing around.
And at the end, when you're done,
we can maybe try a shot where you take off...
Or not, it's better: we recognize you in any case.
When it comes to my job,
I no longer have any doubts.
When I'm on set, I'm where I belong.
However, when it comes to me, the relationship
I have with myself, my life as a woman,
those are other issues, and yes:
I'm far from being a strong women.
If you'd see me crying in my bed
because of a yes or a no,
I'd say...
No, I'm not a strong woman.
And then you, when he gives you the gun, you
can mess around with it a little bit, you know...
Whether people love you or hate you, what's
important in life is to not leave them indifferent.
Whether people love you or hate you,
you've accomplished your mission.
Even today, when we're shooting
video clips or even movies,
people who bring us down saying
"it's cliché, it's this and that",
I answer "Listen, whatever happens, you
checked it out and you have things to say...
And you're thinking about the subject" so
our objective is definitely accomplished.
Okay! And cut!
Come on guys, let's stay focused
because this, this isn't good.
Come on, let's get back to it!
I first met Leïla in 2008, I think.
If you want, you can grab this.
The fact that I'm working with
a woman like Leïla Sy nowadays,
it makes me forget the question
of "is she a women or not".
We have a very special relationship.
So you know what? You're going to hurry,
start putting it on and then sit down.
Nowadays, if a man, for example,
tried to take her spot,
it would be extremely complicated for him.
Okay, back in position.
I have the feeling that women have always
been a part of rap and the hip hop scene.
To start, women are huge rap listeners and
they've always been a part of the story.
What I like is the fight.
The fight gives you an energy
that enables you to transcend.
We live in a society where
it's complicated for women
It's misogynistic. But in reality: I have
other things to share right now than to say:
"Yes, it's true that in my setting
it's like this, it's like that"
It's like this, it's like that!
I'm not gonna shoot myself in the foot.
Yeah, it's like that. But, open your
eyes and look at the world we live in,
how complicated it is for us women.
It's a tough setting but it's actually
hard everywhere for the girls,
and you know it, we know it,
even though for me we're turning the tide
and finding in our femininity,
in our gaze, something very powerful.
I think it's actually the best being a woman.
Sorry boys, but now we're entering the era of women
and we're at the top of our game, and that's the way it is.
It's all a matter of mentality, actually.
The look, Cherine! The look!
That's it!
And... Cut!
Speaking of some of the best girls in the rap game,
we were lucky enough to meet Pauline Duarte
who's been blowing everything up
for years in the French rap scene
and who now runs the Def Jam Label.
Girl power!
It's a historical label who's
managed to stand the test of time:
IAM, Kool Shen, Disiz la Peste,
and today they're still standing with
Koba LaD, Kaaris, Kalash Kriminel and many others.
Right now, we'll meet her with one of her artists.
And they're listening to his new EP.
I've been in rap all my life,
I'm a rap baby.
Nice!
Very, very nice.
I don't mind investing in clips, investing in image or content,
of course, but I want everything to be coherent.
I don't want us to keep doing things that aren't coherent.
I want us to be coherent
and you're the one in charge, you're
the one who's going to make the music.
Today, I may be in a
more modern rap style
with artists who have all been
very pleased to work with me,
because having a woman's opinion
in music is something else.
You put this in the documentary.
She's a star, big star!
Mateo, major business manager,
manager of Soprano and Alonzo.
She taught me everything I know.
The little that I know, she's
the one who taught it to me.
And he, he took everything from me.
Real artists, there are few of them
and the ones who succeed are really
those who put all their heart into it.
Sit down.
Alright, the office is filling up...
the walls are filling
up with gold records!
Admire, admire! I got a
lot of them on the floor.
They don't want to
hang them for me.
Rap is entertainment.
What happens in rap lyrics,
that's not the reality.
My rappers, they're very raw, very
hardcore and they're big teddy bears.
Pauline, I came to talk to you about the new
artists that I'm developing in the company.
For me, rap means to work hard.
For a first try, this is really good.
He's a hard worker.
For now, he has his traditional job
and I think that's good.
He didn't give up his job thinking:
"I'm rapping and right now..." No, no.
We're the first ones.
I am the first woman to run a rap label in France.
I have experienced injustices
as a woman in this industry.
With the same skills,
you see guys walking past you,
we give them labels.
You, you're not going anywhere, you're stuck.
You have to make some moves.
Every time I've seen that it wasn't
going anywhere, I decided to leave.
Am I staying?
I'm good here, I have my small salary....
Yeah, but actually, I want more!
In fact, I want to tear it all up!
So why can he do it?
I know he's not as good as I am.
That's the most important thing,
I know it, you don't know it?
I'll show you.
Now we're going to show that....
Among women, there is still a lot of unity.
Yeah....
We all know each other.
I've never heard a woman speak badly
of another woman in the rap game.
Since the others are taking care of that!
That's clear!
It's too hard already.
As soon as a woman is promoted,
it's important for all women.
You have to be brave, you have to ask,
you have to stop being afraid
and you have to have faith in yourself.
I know it's easy to say, what's sure
is that we must educate our daughters
to be strong women, to be like boys.
It's the same thing,
it goes through education.
Today, men have changed, they're not
the same men they were in the '80s.
Society is changing.
Years ago, women in rap, it was
a lot of big butts in video clips.
and in people's subconscious, it's mainly that.
To this day still
we have to change things.
That's why it's important
to show the women of rap.
It's not only about big butts in clips.
There are other things.
Do you understand me?
"Not just big butts in the clips."
I told you, there's more
than just twerking in rap!
There's more than just twerking!
The last of this shock trio is Rajaa.
She went from Bobigny to Sciences Po,
from Sciences Po to Wati B
and she's been killing
it for 10 years now.
When you hear Rajaa,
you think Wati B.
But when you hear Wati B,
you think Sexion Assault, 4Keus, Black M...
Lots of French rap icons
coming to your ears.
You listened to them for a while!
Rajaaa manages all the musical
projects of the Wati B label,
I might as well tell you that never stops.
Hello?
Okay, I'm arriving at door 30.
Come on.
Hello?
VIP area.
I'll come and get you.
Chief?
I'm putting this down, I have
to go get an official person.
They are with me,
they have bracelets.
I discovered rap as a listener,
I was absolutely not immersed
in this universe as a child.
Thank you guys!
All good, everything's going well?
Great.
I'm almost out of battery, this
is going to become a problem.
In emails, people often
write to me: "Hello sir"...
I don't usually call them out.
And when they call me on the phone, they say:
"Oh, but you're a woman?"
And yes, that's the little surprise.
Girls, won't you say hello?
She is the President of the
Ile-de-France region, our region.
A feminist, for me, is
a woman who's determined,
who's trying to fight against
the barriers of self-censorship.
- How many people are here?
- 20,000 people!
We said "Unity makes strength".
We said it, we did it.
We're together,
we're not going anywhere.
Rajaaa, I saw her, she was this small,
she was at school.
She came to the Wati-Shop
when I first started.
I saw it, I felt that
she had huge potential.
It's a difficult environment,
you have to hold on tight,
sometimes you're gonna cry.
Sometimes you're gonna do things,
or people are going to tell you tough things.
Rajaaa today, for me, is solid.
There's no gender difference in reality.
Why? Why? Because everything
I ask her to do,
she can do it and in addition,
she has character.
I can only congratulate her
and I hope she'll stay with me.
Founding member of Wati B.
There's Dawala, there's
Sexion Assault and JR.
A girl when she gets into something,
especially in professions
where it's usually a man's job.
It's manly, it's tough,
they have to work twice as hard.
Guys, they're going to smoke joints,
they're going to get up at 2-3 in the afternoon
It's also good that there
are women to show people
that it's not such a
misogynistic environment,
it's not such a
tough environment.
When you're younger, you don't
necessarily have faith in yourself,
so we take it upon ourselves....
In reality, we're putting up with it.
We're going to try to make you feel like....
sometimes you don't belong, but it
happened more often when I was younger.
All week long, it's a label that'll
be in the spotlight, mythical label,
the Wati B label with his Wati-Boss,
Mr. Dawala, how are you, Dawala?
Well, it went well this weekend.
Yes, because there was Mali
night on Saturday night.
Many artists?
About fifty artists.
- Other guests who've just arrived....
- The Bât'7 is here.
The older you get, the more
we become experts in our field.
The more confidence you have,
the more you know what you're saying.
But nowadays, I can't be sent back
to my "woman's place".
You can either talk to me
about my skills or nothing else.
You don't talk to me about age
or gender for that matter.
So the good news of the day,
is that in French rap,
there's room for women.
So, girls, do you want to
start rapping? You like it?
Submit your application!
Put your resume on, they'll take this!
Pauline Duarte....
Leïla Sy...
Rajaaa.....
Anyway, guys, there's room for women,
there's room for men.
So if you like rap,
take your chances.
Acknowledgements: Beau Marly and Studio Delta